chers amis
merci
merci nous voilà réunis nous voilà
ensemble heureux de l'être nous
gaullistes libéraux radicaux centristes
nous républicain c'est un nouveau départ
c'est une nouvelle énergie pour nos
idées
c'est un nouvel espoir dans une france
malmené des bouchauds les inquiète
soyons et nous le sommes à la hauteur de
ce rendez-vous est digne de l'ambition
que nous faisons naître avant d'ouvrir
cette séquence
je vais d'abord vous remercier la
politique accélère la vie dans ce
qu'elle a de pire et dans ce qu'elle a
de meilleur
elle est parfois dure et injuste
j'en ai payé le prix pendant cinq ans
j'ai dû affronter avec ma famille une
incessante et effrayante avalanche
d'accusations ma famille politique vous
mes amis militants hommes et femmes de
conviction vous n'avez sans cesse
soutenu même au plus fort de la tempête
médiatique et judiciaire
merci merci pour votre force
merci de ne pas avoir douté
merci de votre affection
merci de votre confiance
merci infiniment merci du fond de mon
coeur
la politique chers amis républicains
ce ne doit plus être de petits calculs
au service de petite cause la république
que nous voulons n'est pas la république
de la haine ou celle de la malveillance
nous la laissons à d'autres nous la
laissons à madame aubry à monsieur
bartolone ou à madame le pen la
politique
notre politique c'est le service des
français la politique ce sont pas
uniquement des choix économiques sociaux
techniques des décisions compliquées
trop souvent incomprise c'est d'abord de
révéler ce qu'il y a de meilleur en
chaque peuple c'est de donner une
dignité à chaque homme et puis comme
aujourd'hui
la politique c'est de se rassembler pour
dire qu'il n'ya aucune fatalité au long
déclin socialiste de la france depuis
trois ans
le chômage atteint des sommets quand
ailleurs il a baissé depuis trois ans
nos déficits publics sont scotchés à 4%
quand les autres pays les ont
considérablement réduit depuis trois ans
nos impôts et nos dépenses publiques ne
cesse de progresser et asphyxient les
ménages et les entreprises
face à une telle situation nous devons
réagir l'économie dans une république
est porteuse de valeurs l'économie
républicaine doit redonner un sens à la
liberté d'entreprendre et de travailler
l'entreprise doit être au centre de
notre projet le travail c'est la liberté
et la dignité de l'homme
on travaille trop peu en france dans la
semaine comme tout au long de la vie et
le travail appelle le travail la liberté
au travail c'est aussi de ne pas
empêcher le travail par un code qui
entravent et empêche l'embauchent la
réussite par le travail
c'est évidemment de faire profiter
chaque salarié chaque employé des succès
de l'entreprise en lien intéressant
beaucoup plus l'économie républicaine
c'est aussi l'égalité légalité comme
moteur de croissance et d'emploi
l'égalité salariale entre les hommes et
les femmes l'égalité entre le secteur
public
et le secteur privé l'égalité entre
l'ensemble de nos territoires
l'économie républicaine c'est enfin la
fraternité n'a fraternité ce n'est pas
de financer par la dette les dépenses
d'aujourd'hui la fraternité ce n'est pas
de faire payer par nos enfants ce que
nous n'avons pas eu le courage de
réformer nous mêmes
alors oui soyons généreux mais pas avec
l'argent des autres
refonder refonder notre modèle social
moins de dépenses publiques moins
d'impôts et de charges cher françois
- de normes moins d'instabilité c'est
plus d'investissements et plus d'emplois
l'économie républicaine c'est une
économie faite pour les citoyens c'est
innover c'est osé c'est fort mais c'est
décidé c'est protéger comme nous le
faisons ensemble
aujourd'hui la france est belle la
france est forte
diverses est ouverte les mes chers amis
c'est d'abord la réformer